"CSI" is entirely fictional, but to give it
the feeling of reality, actress Marg Helgenberger
watched real-life autopsies.
Keep watching to find out what stuck with
her from her encounters with cadavers.
The original CSI changed television forever.
It revamped the police procedural, introducing
a forensic science component that had been
missing from crime dramas before then.
Up until that point, law enforcement shows
focused more on the down-and-dirty, street-level
aspect of fighting crime.
Plots saw police officers and detectives hitting
the streets, using their gumption more than
technology to solve cases.
But in 2000, science was moving forward.
Years earlier, the OJ Simpson trial made the
general public more aware of how DNA evidence
worked, and people were ready to accept a
show heavy with technobabble.
Enter CSI: Crime Scene Investigation.
The show may have gone off the air in 2015,
but it forever changed the genre.
In addition to introducing a slew of spinoffs,
the beloved series launched the careers of
many of its stars.
Marg Helgenberger played an exotic dancer-turned-forensic
scientist named Catherine Willows.
Like Dexter from Dexter, Catherine was a blood
spatter expert.
She was able to analyze how blood fell in
a crime scene to reconstruct how a death took
place.
But unlike most real crime scene investigators,
the agents in CSI were extremely multidisciplinary.
Catherine photographed and analyzed blood
spray, but she also interrogated criminals,
put evidence through a centrifuge, and performed
autopsies.
And it was while preparing for that latter
aspect of her role that Helgenberger may have
taken method acting a little too far.
Method acting is the process of going in-depth
with a role.
For example, an actor playing an archaeologist
may study some of the basic principles so
that they can sound more like they know what
they're talking about during the performance.
They may even try on a profession to better
prepare for a part, like when Tom Cruise got
a job as a UPS worker so that he could blend
in with a crowd for his role in Collateral.
Marg Helgenberger actually attended autopsies
to prepare for the role of Catherine Willows
in CSI.
The producers did not mandate this, but she
insisted that she wanted to get a more in-depth
education on how the entire crime scene investigation
process worked in real life.
In 2011, she explained to BBC Breakfast,
"I asked for it and I was glad that I did
because it's something that doesn't ever leave
you.
You'll always have that very strong sense
memory of the experience."
Helgenberger followed along with criminologists
in Las Vegas.
She did a ride-along to a report of a dead
body at the Hard Rock Hotel, then was able
to attend the autopsy and follow the weeks-long
process.
In the same interview, she said,
"I was able to track the whole case because
then I exchanged email addresses with the
coroner because obviously the toxicology report
takes a few weeks."
She also shared one of the more unsettling,
visceral details from her time witnessing
an autopsy being performed:
"The smell is probably the most intense thing
about it."
Unpleasant smells aside, CSI wasn't the only
show where she went method.
Marg Helgenberger has had a long, lucrative
career in the industry.
Even after CSI ended, she hasn't been short
on work, appearing in a litany of TV and film
projects, including Under the Dome, Almost
Friends, and A Dog's Journey.
However, her most prominent role outside of
CSI would arguably have to be All Rise.
The legal drama received critical acclaim
when it ran on OWN for two seasons before
being prematurely canceled.
Helgenberger played series regular Judge Lisa
Benner, and to get in the right mindset for
the character, the actress went back to her
method acting roots.
She explained how she prepared for the role
in an interview with AARP, and it involved
utilizing some family connections:
"My Georgetown Law student son interned for
a woman judge [about my age] in Pasadena.
I got to sit in her courtroom and meet her.
It's fascinating — the precision needed
to decide who's telling the truth and who's
stretching the truth."
She also mentions in the same interview how
All Rise allowed her to build on what she
had done during CSI.
She elaborated,
"I've been a lot of cops, detectives and a
criminalist on CSI, but never played a prosecutor
or a judge.
All Rise reminds me of the early days of L.A.
Law — it has great dramatic writing but
also levity."
With any luck, Helgenberg's next role will
remain in the law enforcement sphere so that
she can continue putting all of this training
to good use.
"I won't miss swabbing somebody's mouth, that's
for sure."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.